We're not going to talk today now about Carolingian decline.
Uh,
it's not just that we're compressing lectures or in a hurry.
And the empire of Charlemagne is an empire that does not last that long.
So when we say that it has certain flaws like size,
well we already said that the Roman Empire had this flaw.
We've already said that the Abbasid Caliphate has this floor floor,
but those empires are able to manage with this weakness for quite some time.
Um,
part of the problem with the Carolingian empire is its size part of it.
However,
as you will have read in,
uh,
the,
fished in our reading is it's lack of infrastructure and economic development
infrastructure in the sense of not just towns,
roads,
communications,
but a social infrastructure.
The lack of an idea of obeying the state or obeying the ruler and a tendency
therefore to mix private and public interest and to the benefit of the powerful.
Uh,
we'll talk more about that.
There are also external problems,
the beginnings of the Viking invasions,
which we will be talking about,
uh,
after the break,
occur before Charlemagne death in eight 14.
But nevertheless,
there's no sense hastening the signs of decline.
We always can see signs of decline coming after.
Uh,
but,
um,
Charlemagne's rule had been so successful,
so full of accomplishments.
He was a ruler of such prestige,
uh,
that even the difficult last 10 years or so of his reign can't quite it clips
that.
Um,
in,
uh,
eight oh one,
there arrived an elephant at the court of Charlemagne,
a gift from the Caliph of Baghdad,
Iran,
Al Rashid,
the Caliph who figures in the Arabian nights,
entertainments.
Uh,
this is a link between two very powerful and very distant empires.
The two of the three that we've described as in some sense heirs to the Roman
classical empire and civilization.
Uh,
there was a kind of tentative thought of perhaps in alliance,
uh,
between Baghdad and him at capital of Charlotte,
Maine's a empire.
Um,
at various times there had been negotiations between Constantinople and Ah,
and over,
uh,
the,
um,
discussing the possibility of an imperial marriage.
The Carolingian ruler was contemptuous of Byzantium though because it was ruled
by a woman,
the emperor Irene rather figure.
Um,
but,
uh,
neither the alliance with Byzantium,
at least at this point,
and certainly not the more far fetched alliance with Baghdad came to anything.
The elephant was certainly the first one seen in Europe probably since Hannibal
and his,
uh,
attempt to,
well,
his invasion of Italy.
Um,
and,
uh,
you know,
how he got there,
what the logistics of his transport work,
how he got to Baghdad in the first place.
It's not as if they have elephants in the natural habitat of Iraq,
either.
Nevertheless,
hears this elephant who lives for about 10 years.
Uh,
one of the signs of things starting to unravel in the Carolingian empire,
so some historians say is the death of Charlemagne,
is elephant,
which Einhard talks about actually in his biography.
That is,
it is an event that's worth mentioning.
Uh,
but I,
you know,
pets,
they,
you know,
they don't last forever.
And you've got it.
It's someone who lost his cat,
uh,
within recent memory.
You just got to get over it.
On the other hand,
I,
I can get another cat and Charlemagne presumably,
well,
not presumably we know he didn't get another elephant.
The high watermark of his reign seems to be the year eight oh two.
I mean,
this is arbitrary,
but,
uh,
this is shown by the energy of his quarrel with the Byzantine emperors over his
arrogating to himself,
the title of Emperor,
Right.
That's the first person in the west claiming to be emperor.
And the Byzantine Empire doesn't like it.
Uh,
by eight Oh two,
he is done with his two campaigns,
one in Spain,
uh,
and the other in Saxony and the regions of the Danube.
He had pacified the Saxons after a nearly 20 year effort.
Uh,
and while he hadn't achieved his ambitions in Spain,
um,
he had a seize territory in the northern part of what's now Catalonia.
He attempted to address the problem that I've just identified,
namely the tendency of powerful people to take over,
uh,
um,
and rule localities not as government servants,
but as noble rulers.
Uh,
he,
um,
in order to combat that,
tried to get everybody,
every free man in his realm to swear an oath to him personally,
that is to make sure that they understood that their prime loyalty had to be to
the emperor and not to the count.
Duke,
uh,
local ruler,
bishop,
whoever he was
and the instructions that he gave to the men's sent out to try and,
um,
to administer this oath.
Show you some of his idea of rulership.
We've talked about this already,
but since it's a fairly complex idea,
it's worth,
um,
yeah,
emphasizing in the instructions it says,
let each man keep himself in the sacred service of God following the divine
commandment and observing whatever promise he may have made fully to the best of
under his understanding and powers for the Lord.
Emperor cannot exercise his vigilance or powers of correction over every man.
So the notion that the emperor is supposed to be responsible for people behaving
themselves is responsible for not just what we would call political order or
piece,
but for the salvation of the people.
For the spiritual as well as a political health of the realm is uh,
typically Carolingian and in a way,
typically mid evil.
There's a sense of imperial responsibility before God for the behavior of the
emperors subjects.
But already a few years later and eight Oh six,
this idea has been weakened
in eight oh six.
If you take a look at the first map that I've given out,
we have a partition in eight oh six,
an agreement at a place called [inaudible] veal.
I guess this is going to have to be spelled out since we don't have chalked t,
and it's written on the first,
well now it just says proposed partition in eight Oh six,
he came up with the idea of dividing his realm.
Yeah.
Uh,
upon his three children,
his son Charles would get the north,
his son Pepin would get Lombardi in Bavaria and his son Louis would have
Aquitaine in this document.
There's no mention of the imperial title leading one to surmise that maybe he
thought this title was just his personal accomplishment.
Maybe he didn't really envisage the reestablishment of the Roman Empire in any
kind of permanent way.
Okay.
Here we just have a kind of splitting up of land.
Louis gets the south west.
Charles gets the lion's share,
the heartlands of the Carolingian family.
Um,
uh,
the parts of Germany that the Carolingian is controlled and northern France and
Pepin gets Italy and the outs.
So here you have a contrast between eight oh two,
this grandiose imperial idea of unity eight Oh six,
uh,
just like the Merovingians partitioning out,
the successor to Charlotte and the lands,
uh,
for the successors of Charlemagne.
Ah,N is a long way from being another Byzantium Constantinople or another
Baghdad.
And in these low capiche hilarious.
The documents that are issued by the court of instructions to the administrators
we do see as fished.
And how emphasizes a sense of,
um,
unease and have problems again and again.
The capitulate,
Larry's lament,
corruption maladministration.
Okay.
Uh,
they start to mention the vikings as a more than just a minor mosquito bite
level,
um,
distraction.
But most of all they emphasize usurpation of royal authority.
Usurpation meaning again,
that the people such as the counts or Duke's or the nobles who are supposed to
be servants of the crown,
supposed to be his chief servants,
are taking over for themselves.
Things like taxes,
revenues,
the right of judgment,
the right to punish people.
And people are tending to look at them as their rulers.
But count of Flanders,
the count of Barcelona,
the Duke of Aquitaine.
These are people who are starting to think of themselves as potentially at least
rulers who might transmit their office to their children.
And if then is not an office,
it's a possession if you have a right of inheritance.
In other words,
uh,
um,
I could transmit to my children my 10 year old car,
uh,
um,
my,
silver butter dish,
all of my treasured possessions,
but I cannot transmit to them the professorship that I have.
I can't just say,
well,
you know,
my eldest son is going to be a professor of medieval history at Yale.
Whether or not he has any interest in doing that because I don't own the
position,
uh,
I don't,
it's not my property.
It is my office.
We're so familiar with this that we don't even think about what it would be
like.
Well,
we actually do because there are some things that people do tend to start to own
that originally were not supposed to be that way.
But,
uh,
in the Medieval world,
it is a problem to dislodge people from property because properties in land,
all Yale has to do is stop paying me and I'm no longer benefiting from this
office.
On the other hand,
if I had a castle,
um,
you know,
across campus and some stored,
some boiling pit and some followers naturally,
uh,
some,
you know,
trustee drinking mates.
And,
um,
you know,
had this,
a little a moat and by he establishment,
uh,
right outside of harkness I could terrorize yet,
and extort from it.
And the picture is not so far fence where the picture,
where the picture is really not far fetched because if you imagine Yale in
ruins,
um,
people pastoring sheep on cross campus and wondering God,
what were those buildings anyway,
I hear you really huge.
And,
and all those funny little blackboards,
whatever they were for a,
and then,
you know,
using Wla to build,
um,
you know,
fortifications,
why build a new castle on the lawn when you can,
um,
you know,
you've got building materials that somebody else left for you.
So,
you know,
WLA h one 17,
one 16,
one 15,
or one person's fortress and uh,
you know,
that auditorium at the other end,
the is somebody else's.
And A,
here,
I'm getting a little bit ahead of myself,
but this is what's going to happen once the Carolingian empire dissolves.
Essentially we're going to have,
when I say people USERP or arrogated or make hereditary their possessions.
Uh,
I'm talking about something that sounds abstract,
but if you think of it in terms of what it means to defy people.
Um,
basically you're talking about building castles and this has to do with the
nature of warfare.
This is all a subject for the courses exceeds this one,
but,
um,
it has to do with the nature of warfare in the sense that once you have that
castle,
it's very hard to be dislodged from it.
The advantages with the defense,
um,
catapults,
Trevi,
Shay's all these interesting weapons actually both require an insane amount of
mobilization and organization and are not as effective as artillery.
Uh,
some centuries later is going to be
so the problems of Charlemagne,
his empire,
despite the invasions that will be our subject for um,
uh,
Monday after thanksgiving.
The problems of Charlemagne's empire are essentially internal as was the case of
the Roman Empire.
Only more so these internal problems,
what I've called the lack of infrastructure,
which means political and economic infrastructure make it very difficult
effectively to resist the Vikings.
And there are other invaders whom will have to mention as well later on the
Hungarians.
Um,
and um,
uh,
invaders and Raiders from North Africa.
The empire was too large given the nature of communications and the
okay
mechanisms available to impose order.
It had the same thing that made it an empire,
uh,
made it have some disadvantages.
Diversity of population.
Okay.
Um,
ethnic loyalties.
so you have revolts of Aquitania ones who are not Frank's of Britain's people in
Brittany who are not Frank's Bavarians Visigoths.
All of these people are not necessarily overjoyed with Frankish rural,
not necessarily immune from the possibility of seizing on the weakness of the
Franks to rebel.
These problems become more manifest in the reign of Charlemagne son Louis,
the pious who rolls from eight 14 to eight 40.
My hesitation in using the word rules is that he has deposed once and forced to
go undergo public penance twice.
Okay.
One of the problems of the empire was obviated.
However,
when Charlemagne died in eight 14,
the succession was just to Lewis because his brothers had died.
So the eight oh six or eight,
oh six plan was not implemented,
uh,
and became moot.
Charlemagne was succeeded by one sole ruler over the entire empire.
Louis the pious because Pepin and Charles had died.
Okay.
Lewis is often seen as inept,
but well meaning his sobriquet and a lot of the Carolingian rulers now have
less flattering men.
Pious Charles the bald,
well,
you know,
that seems a little unfair.
Um,
Charles,
the simple Charles the fat Louis the stammer Louis the child,
um,
you get the idea,
I'm not unimposing group of rulers,
but pious,
shouldn't us be a compliment?
And indeed,
um,
uh,
it could be,
and,
and as it happens,
he's not known as Louis the pious in every language.
Uh,
so in German he's referred to as low as the pious,
but in French,
uh,
he's,
Louis,
the debonair,
the,
uh,
imposing.
He is an imposing figure.
Actually.
He's not as weak as what I'm going to say,
uh,
in the rest of the discussion about him is going to make him look.
He was a very effective general.
He did a lot of,
uh,
wars in southern France.
He was the effective ruler of Aquitaine.
He,
um,
uh,
conquered a Barcelona for Charlemagne.
Uh,
he suffered from three problems,
however,
um,
one not at all of his own making the second,
uh,
certainly exacerbated by his vacillation.
Uh,
and the third is just who he was.
The first problem is the invasions.
The Viking invasions in particular begin during his reign,
the first part of the ninth century.
And,
um,
so it's an external problem.
On the other hand,
the lack of an effective response
does have to do with,
um,
flaws in the nature of Carolingian rule flaws in the nature of Lewis's rule in
particular.
The second problem is his sons,
his sons fought against each other and against their father.
This is not something that's new to us.
We've seen this with the Merovingians,
but in order to maintain control of,
uh,
sons who expect some kind of rulership and who are jockeying for power,
with their siblings,
um,
Lewis made it worst in part because he had sons by two marriages and tried to
carve out another realm for his youngest son,
Charles,
the Bald Charles.
The future,
the bald.
I mean,
I don't know that he was called Charles the bald when he was 14.
I actually don't know when that title starts to come into effect,
not title,
nickname.
Um,
as we'll see,
these civil wars have greater significance than mere civil wars because they're
at the origins of the breaking up of the empire into entities that we can just
about start to call France and Germany.
So we're at the kind of crucible or moment of creation of the European order
that will exist for the next,
uh,
more than 1000 years.
Lewis had very sophisticated ideas about imperial rule,
perhaps even more sophisticated than those of his father because Louis was quite
a,
a bit more educated than Charlemagne,
quite literate.
Um,
one might almost say an intellectual as well as an effective general,
but he was less pragmatic,
less realistic,
less flexible than his father.
Even more than Charlemagne.
Lewis believed that the emperor must answer before God for the conduct of his
population.
Even more than Charlemagne.
He believed that he ruled over a,
um,
a sanctified state.
In other words,
he was not just a political ruler.
He was,
in some sense,
a religious leader that the religious and the political,
we're not to be distinguished.
If the state is a religious entity,
does it mean that the state rules over the church or if it's a religious entity,
perhaps it means that the church rules over the state.
It can go either way.
When Charlemagne was crowned by the pope,
he certainly indicated a conception of rulership sanctified by the church.
He was not at all worried about the pope dictating to him.
He had rescued the pope from the Roman mob.
The pope was utterly dependent on him.
Okay,
okay.
But that is not necessarily the way things would be and Louis had less to worry
about from the pope's then from his own bishops taking his rulership as a sacred
trust.
Seriously meant that an eight 22 he appeared at a place called [inaudible],
eight t.
Apt to me in the church of at t need covered with ashes and dressed in sack
cloth.
The Bible describes and which I guess burlap would be the best kind of modern
equivalent.
So dressed in,
you know,
kind of rags,
literally covered with ashes to ask forgiveness for the way in which the
rebellion of his nephew Bernard had been suppressed.
Not only were his sons restless,
but his nephew had rebelled,
been captured,
been blinded and died the blinding or maybe the knew how to do it better in
Byzantium.
Um,
we're supposed to be a more humane alternative,
rendering them unfit to rule but sparing his life.
But in the NT.
Dot.
Louis was full of remorse for this and did a public act of penance.
And we know from the experience of all forms of rulership,
including modern,
that there are ways of saying you're sorry and ways of not saying you're sorry.
The problem with a political officer or ruler saying they are sorry is that it
may make them look weak.
Okay.
It may make them lose their aura of leadership.
The problem with them not saying they're sorry.
In modern.
The modern world of course,
is also very great and it's very tricky to negotiate a line of,
um,
that preserves,
but also gives at least the impression of candor.
Louis does not have Charlemagne instinctive charisma of leadership.
The pennants at at teeny resulted in his,
uh,
loss of prestige
and a great increase in the power of the church.
So there's always been an implicit danger of this.
Once Frankish end Christian ideas of rulership were merged.
Charlemagne,
as I've said,
had no problem with us,
but Louis did already in eight 29 Pope Gregory the fourth would claim is not the
authority oversouls,
which belongs to the pope above the imperial rule,
which is of this world.
Right.
The implication here is that because the spiritual is superior to the material
in moral terms,
and why is the spiritual superior to the material was sort of Plato's republic
kind of question.
I'm just saying this.
Yes.
Morality over,
you know,
like the pleasures of loss and not merely morality over the pleasures of lost.
What's,
what's the problem with the pleasures of lust from the Killjoy Plato's Republic
point of view?
They end,
right?
they are mortal,
they die.
And so is all matter.
By definition,
all matter fades.
So which is superior,
the spiritual or the material,
the spiritual doesn't die.
The spiritual is immortal.
That's what makes it spiritual.
That's what the forms or reality or the higher,
the invisible,
but real.
Okay.
To put ourselves in the mindset of eight 29,
of course,
we have to admit that,
you know,
you may not feel that,
uh,
I'm not,
I'm not urging this upon you as a worldview.
You may think that there is no such thing as a spirit,
or you may think that the spiritual is as mortal as the material,
but I think 29 people would agree.
Yeah.
Okay.
The spiritual is superior to the material because it's a mortal in the material
withers and dies.
But does that mean that the spiritual has got to rule the material?
That's the question for the ages,
at least for the medieval ages.
So Louis,
the pious and his sons in eight 17 Lewis issues an order map number B,
to
divvy up the realm and the event of his death.
Uh,
order called the [inaudible] Perry,
the ordering of the empire.
This unlike Charlemagne's division really expresses an idea of imperial rule.
Louis associates with himself,
his eldest son,
low Thar and look at how big their territory is.
First of all,
it's huge.
It encompasses the Carolingian ancestral lands and basically the other sons,
Louis,
the German Bernard and Pippin are given,
uh,
a bunch of,
um,
uh,
a bunch of,
you know,
sort of adjunct lambs.
And in fact,
I'm sorry,
I said that,
uh,
Bernard is not his son as his nephew.
Uh,
and,
and this is what Bernard rebels and counts the rebellion that will cause his
blinding and death.
Is this what he regarded as a few crumbs from the table rather than a full
share?
The real problem begins,
uh,
however,
even after our ta in a 25 when Lewis,
his second wife gave birth to a son named Charles,
thus complicating the succession,
his second wife Judith,
urged him to fit Charles into the succession.
And this enraged the older sons from his first marriage.
In
29 a council met at Paris and while Charles was given a share,
the bishops of the realm also claimed the right to judge the king by his
performance.
In eight 31 eight rebellion,
a second or third rebellion broke out the sons of Louis the pious,
although fighting against each other,
allied,
but church regarded Lewis now is hopelessly ineffectual,
incapable of bringing order to the realm.
And Louis was captured by his sons,
forced to abdicate.
Okay.
Both by the church and by a low Thor and Louis,
his older sons.
Luther was so arrogant,
however,
that by eight 34 Lewis had been restored.
Uh,
um,
I won't go into the,
uh,
complexities of this.
Suffice it to say that the hapless or at least unlucky Louis,
the pious when he died in eight 40 provoked another war of succession among his
sons.
Keep in mind that meanwhile the administration of the empire is dissolving and
the Viking invasions are occupying ever more attention in effectual attention
and plundering.
Yeah.
Even more.
Okay.
After a series of battles and uh,
um,
campaigns in eight 43 a partition took place,
but this one is really important.
This is the treaty of [inaudible] done V,
e,
r,
d,
u,
N and that's the third one on your map that I have bold or at least felt tipped
lines showing the division.
And then on page two of the handout,
um,
on the upper part is the division of very done.
The treaty over done divided the empire among the three sons of Louis,
the pious three surviving sons.
The western part went to Charles the bald.
Okay.
And you see that in white,
new Straya Aquitaine Spanish mark.
Uh,
it is what can start to be called France,
the eastern part,
which is the darkest Saxony eastern Australia,
Allah Marnia Bavaria went to Lewis's son Louis,
also named Louis Louis the German as he's known to historians.
And he's known as Louis the German in part because his sphere of influence was
the east,
which we can start to call Germany.
The eldest son low thar got the middle part,
which stretches from what's now the northern part of the Netherlands free.
Zia.
All the way down to Rome and even a little south of Rome.
Spoleto.
Okay.
This is the most prestigious and in some ways,
richest part of the empire.
It has ochin the imperial capitol,
and it has Rome,
the old imperial capital.
It has,
uh,
the lands of the Carolingian,
most of them in,
uh,
the region of [inaudible] in the region of the low countries,
modern Belgium.
Uh,
what's the problem with this realm hour?
What's the obvious military political problems,
you know,
can see we're very hard to defend,
be easy to cut off and invade.
And if we say that the western part is France and we say that the eastern part
is Germany using these terms anachronistically but not inaccurately.
What is the middle part?
The middle part is all that part of Europe that has been fought over all of
world war one takes place in the,
uh,
on the western front.
Most of it takes place in the northern part of the realm of love from
the places where like Belgium,
which to this day is oh wow.
Now is bitterly divided between frank speaking and Flemish speaking.
In other words,
people who speak a Germanic language
descended from some ancestral Germanic language and those who speak French
descended from Latin.
That line runs right through Belgium.
Uh,
and the same ambiguity pursues this whole realm of low Thor's down into
Switzerland,
a modern polity,
what modern,
late medieval and modern,
uh,
where they speak four official languages and are so unsure about which is the
official one that their stamps give the name of the country in Latin and their
airline gives its name in English,
right?
Their stamps call themselves.
Hell,
Vizient.
There has not been an entity called that really in sort of real life terms since
the Roman empire,
but that's uh,
you know,
that's better than having all four languages on there that's more convenient.
So there's a linguistic ambiguity,
there's a,
um,
cultural ambiguity and there's a political ambiguity because of course the realm
of low thar didn't hold up very long.
It's strategic flaw was very quickly manifested.
It was divided but never permanently.
Part of this realm would be called what in French is called low rain,
but in German it's called low training load.
[inaudible]
named after loath,
e m,
Alsace and Lorraine.
These two provinces are now France in 1870.
They were taken by Germany after World War One.
They were taken back by France under Hitler.
They became a next to Germany after World War II.
They're back with France.
A substantial proportion of the population of Alsace still speaks German.
And until about 70,
80 years ago,
a fairly significant proportion of low rain did as well.
Same kind of ambiguity as to what,
what are these territories?
And in our world,
they either are neither France nor Germany,
hence Belgium,
Netherlands,
Switzerland or they've traded hands.
It is not exactly accurate to say that the political military history of Europe
since eight 43 is simply the unwinding of the consequences of the treaty of very
done.
Uh,
but it's not completely inaccurate to say that either.
That doesn't mean that,
you know,
events like the reformation,
uh,
or,
um,
the second world war don't have significance well beyond that.
But just in terms of border shifting and maps of Europe,
uh,
the legacy of Verdun is tremendous.
If the legacy of Charlemagne is in some sense the creation of a cultural realm
that can be referred to as Europe.
The legacy of the sons of Louis,
the pious is the ambiguous division of that realm.
What this really means then is that the,
in ninth century terms,
since nobody said,
wow,
we're signing the treaty of are done,
this is going to have consequences for centuries,
but immediate consequences were the decreasing relevance,
the decreasing importance of the imperial title.
When low third died and his eldest son died soon after low stars were almost
divided between Lewis and Charles,
then Italy was left to a son of low Thor's called Louis.
The second he took on the imperial title.
Uh,
but,
um,
under Charles,
the bald,
the third and much youngest son of Louis the pious for a little while,
the empire was reunited for a little while,
uh,
meaning basically two years when Charles died in eight 77,
um,
the empire would not be reestablished as unified,
uh,
for almost a century.
And when it was,
it would really consist of basically,
um,
an enlarged Germany and a portion of Italy,
not France.
And Charles,
although he bore between eight 75 and eight 77,
the grand title of emperor and was unchallenged within his own family.
Uh,
his rulership was already severely undermined by,
uh,
the intrigues of his nobles and the Vikings.
Yeah.
By the time of his death,
many of the counties that had originally been administrative divisions of the
empire had become almost independent.
So for example,
Barcelona conquered by Louis,
the pious was now ruled,
um,
after eight 68 by a count who paid nominal allegiance to the ruler of the
western kingdom,
but who was the founder of a dynasty up to eight 68.
Therefore,
you have counts of Barcelona who are appointed by the ruler after eight 68.
The ruler has very little to do with it.
It is a local ruler and the account is no longer an office holder,
but a ruler in his own right.
Uh,
similar with Aquitaine,
similar with Bavaria,
similar with [inaudible] to lose Flanders.
The reason that the counselor able to do this is the weakness of the central
power,
not only because of the personality of the ruler,
but because of the inadequate nature of the administration.
Okay.
When Charles died,
he was succeeded by,
um,
several rulers in the West Louis,
the stammerer Louis the third,
who has the good fortune of just being Louis the third,
uh,
and Carla man.
Um,
in Germany the ruler was Charles the fat
and he was elected as emperor for again,
for years,
but was pretty,
utterly ineffectual and not because he was fat,
I hasten to add on the Middle Ages did not share,
uh,
or,
prejudices in this regard.
So Louis,
the fat in the 12th century,
uh,
was a very effective cow.
Fatter,
not Charles.
This particular Charles was not,
uh,
was not,
an effective ruler.
All of these rulers,
as I said,
suffered the depredations of the vikings.
But once again,
I want to emphasize that the problems of this empire or the problems of the
separate kingdoms or indeed the problems of some of the counties ruled by
independent counts,
but affected by the Vikings.
And other invaders were internal.
The Vikings were opportunistic Raiders,
not the cause of the dissolution of authority.
The dissolution of authority didn't mean that the Carolingian has come to an end
because by this time in the late ninth century,
they have some of the prestige that the mirror of engines had in there.
A decline in their veins flowed the blood of Charlemagne.
They were a sacred dynasty.
They had a certain kind of prestige.
So for example,
they would be kings of France with some minor interruptions until 987
in Germany.
The family ends in nine 11 and a new,
uh,
series of dynasties not comes in,
into effect.
In 1987 a new dynasty comes into rule of France called the Capetian Dynasty.
C A,
P,
e t,
I a,
N A,
which technically runs out in,
um,
13,
14,
but which is related to the French kings since.
And indeed when Louis the 16th,
was Ghia teen by the French Revolution,
he was referred to in the court documents as Louis Copay.
Then as they gave him a kind of artificial last name,
uh,
and regarded him as descended from this ruler.
Hugh Kopay,
CPE t that's a member of the Capetian CIP,
t I a n dynasty.
But the reality of France and even of Germany in the 10th century would be as a
series of nearly independent principalities,
feuding,
uh,
only nominally controlled by the king,
the ruler,
uh,
Huka pay who succeeded in nine 87 basically,
he seems to have controlled the road between Paris and or layoff.
Yeah.
But in places that are now public parks in Paris,
uh,
like a van Song,
there were castle's not loyal to the king at all.
So my little fantasy of,
uh,
a fortified
across campus is not so far fetched,
at least not so far fetched in terms of what really happened in places like
Paris.
And indeed in a,
for example,
the,
uh,
city of RL in southern France,
there's a wonderful,
wonderfully preserved Roman stadium,
Roman sports arena,
uh,
that,
um,
was fortified.
Okay.
That is one family had,
you know,
the bleachers and a have fought against the people who had,
uh,
you know,
the,
um,
the boxes behind home plate,
not a classical term,
but,
uh,
behind what might've been considered home plate in acronystic link.
Uh,
and indeed there are towers built on top of this structure that we're then
demolished because they were medieval and not classical.
Uh,
but,
uh,
they made use of these materials.
So we have a society in which the power of the ruler has literally dissolved,
not dissolved into water,
but certainly crumbled into much smaller components.
Those components being essentially a castle or a few councils,
the territory around it,
the right to exploit the peasants around it.
Maybe you would have an effective regional ruler like the count of Barcelona or
the count of Flanders
who would tie to himself.
These castle lands,
the people who own or run the castles.
But it is a society that has become fragmented.
It's not a barbarian society.
These are not nomads.
Uh,
they're violent.
But then again,
lots of societies run on violence.
It's a controlled kind of violence.
They want to squeeze the peasants,
even occasionally,
perhaps plunder them.
They didn't want to have them go away or exterminate them cause they don't have
any wealth otherwise.
It is an exploitative society.
But that again is not entirely new or entirely unknown and other historical
periods and places.
What it does bring up,
however,
and which I'll try to address in our last class once we've talked about the
vikings,
is what's been accomplished.
Here we are from 380 to the year 1000 and we're still talking about invasion and
we're still talking about polities falling apart because they're too large.
We're still talking about the lack of administrative control over powerful
individuals.
So a,
I promise you that something was accomplished and I will try to describe that,
uh,
um,
next time.
But you're forgiven for thinking that perhaps we have wandered around and not
come very far.
Very good Thanksgiving and I'll see you soon.